after talking to the immigration lawyer
we found out that Usman definitely could
not have a second wife in America
because polygamy is illegal in America
and that would prevent Usman from
getting the green card this puts our
whole future of our relationship in
jeopardy because it's really important
to usman's family and to Usman that he
has a child I unfortunately cannot have
any
so it's um frustrating I'm worried about
our future
I have these
I think I want to tell you about it but
I feel like
Maybe
so do you remember Muhammad's son
yes I'm feeling like
it's not going to be an easy thing what
do you mean
I don't know what you're saying though I
don't understand
so
I feel like maybe I'm going to adopt
wait what what
are you joking right now no I'm not
joking I'm not joking
so you would adopt
the little boy
yeah
okay
um basically all his children are my
children you know that right
if today anything happened to him he
died I have to make sure that his
children are okay to take care of them
is now it is in Nigeria but you got to
give me more of my blood and then so you
can be like my own son
if getting second wife is not something
that can happen I think adopting and if
you mahadi will be the best idea because
it is important in my culture and
tradition to have child but the
connection between me and mahadi is more
important like it's something like I
feel him like I'm very close to him he's
close to me I love him
now I was thinking I would definitely
love to take him to U.S so that he will
not be as struggling as other struggle
here
adopted mahadi is not the best option
for my mom but it's something that she
can accept because my family say that I
need to have my own blood to be my son
and I'm Hadi is my brother's child so we
are blood
[Music]